alex nobile et sur le terrain les yeux
et les oreilles de la direction de
l'alimentation de l'agriculture et des
forêts ici au mans 2 rouges
il doit tout savoir tout connaître des
agriculteurs et des parcelles exploitées
ce matin l'objectif est simple prélevé
des échantillons pour les connaître mais
bon je prends au hasard bon je pense
tous les points du portel
depuis le fameux mesures pour le moment
une quinzaine de pour lui merci je vous
ai fera vite on exploite quatre hectares
plantés en d'achille n'avait choux
pommés ou encore concombres même si son
analyse de sol réalisé en 2008 fait état
d'une présence de chlordécone
il est autorisé malgré tout à cultiver
des légumes et ce type de contrôle le
rassure ces contrôles d'art et même tous
ces produits là et six mois par année
papier stabilité marchandiseur mois mais
pas les rues c'est pour ça ça sent la
bonne voie les prélèvements réalisés
sont ensuite transportés à la daf où ils
seront conditionnés pour être envoyés en
guadeloupe afin d'être analysés donc
conditionnement l'échantillon comme
s'ils étaient rangés dans un magasin de
manière à sénart le produit qu'est
musique est mis en vente de manière à
pas faire analyser de la terre mais bien
le produit consommé dans le présenteur
tout est mis en oeuvre pour garantir une
traçabilité du produit
évidemment la traçabilité élément
essentiel puisque l'échantillon qui est
déjà au départ composé de plusieurs mini
échantillons en laçant pour fernand en
faire un échantillon unique les billets
à une parcelle il est affecté d'un
identifiant très précis qui va permettre
de le suivre au labo retour et
éventuellement s'il ya des mesures à
prendre pour reprise complète par celle
d'agriculteur il faut en moyenne quinze
jours pour obtenir des résultats avant
commercialisation de la production
l'adaf effectué 250 prélèvements par an
dans le cadre des plans de surveillance
et de contrôle à la contamination
chlordécone